Most people think improving their
communication is about learning how to
articulate their thoughts more clearly
and confidently. But after 15 years as a
communication coach, I've learned that
how you think you sound and how you
actually sound to others are two very
different things. And there are 10
speaking habits that are creating this
gap. And I'm going to walk you through
all 10 in order of how much they cost
you professionally. And I'm going to
show you the exact behavior you should
replace those bad ones with so you can
close the gap between how you think you
sound versus how you actually sound and
come across. So let's start with number
10.
And it's still blurry because I'm not
going to reveal it just yet. I want you
to see if you can actually spot what
number 10 is through this example.
>> Um
Andy, I've got a
cup of coffee. Like you know like
like
you want it?
>> Did you manage to work it out? Number 10
is using non-words and filler words.
When you see someone who talks like
this, their speech littered with
non-words and filler words, what are
some words that come to your mind? What
do you perceive about them? You're going
to think they're shy, you're going to
think they're awkward, low levels of
confidence, they're not competent. Can
you see how much this simple
non-functional behavior is costing you?
This is one of the first things I get
our students to minimize immediately
when they join us in our stage programs.
When you speak like this, it sounds like
you're all over the place. It seems like
you're a scatterbrain and there's no
clarity in your speech. To reduce the
non-words and filler words, what what do
you replace it with?
What I just did. A pause. That's it.
That's what you replace it with. Every
time you feel the urge to say um
uh
just pause. Let me show you how powerful
this one change is with one of my
students. Have a look at this.
>> Um so through medical school I've always
wanted to be a physician. So you know
I'm looking after your heart, lungs, and
you know, I just went to the wards
and
>> You're filling a lot of the silence with
the um's, ah's, and the so. No so's,
ah's, or um's. And very conscious of
replacing the um's and the ah's and the
so's
with silence.
>> I went into medical school thinking that
I've always wanted to just
help humanity, save lives,
make changes.
Little did I know that it's not all
about saving lives in that life and
death,
it's about changing quality of life.
>> Big round of applause. How much better
did she sound? Full of confidence and
authority. Now, next, number nine.
Trailing off at the end of your
sentences. This is when you start your
sentences strong like this, but then
after you continue to talk for a while,
your voice starts to lose its energy and
you become really croaky and then all of
a sudden
you start to sound like a villain who is
trying to take over the world.
Do you hear that drop? That's called
vocal fry and it's more common than you
think. Your brain doesn't even register
you're doing it because most people
don't think about how they're speaking.
They only focus on what they're saying.
So, what do you replace this bad habit
with? Then, you give every single word
in the sentence the same amount of
breath and energy that you give to the
very first word. Same fuel from start to
finish. You start your sentences strong
like this and as you continue, make sure
every single word has the same amount of
breath and energy right till the very
last word. Did you notice the
difference? Did you feel the difference?
Did you hear the difference? That's the
line between a communicator who hold
your attention all the way through the
thought and the one who loses you
halfway without even realizing. Now, the
next habit. This one is the equivalent
of handing someone a beautifully wrapped
gift and then whispering, "It's probably
not what you wanted and it's probably
shit." right before they open the gift.
Number eight. Apologizing for your own
ideas. I see this in almost every single
person who's early in their career. They
devalue their own ideas before the other
person has the chance to hear it with a
phrase like, "Sorry, just a quick
question." "It's probably a bad idea,
but I want to say I I I I might be wrong
about this, but um" And what you've done
without realizing is you've told the
listener that you don't truly fully
believe in yourself. You've given them
permission to just dismiss you before
you've even shared the idea. These
verbal flinches are called softeners and
they show up most when we feel like we
haven't earned the right to speak. The
problem is the softener becomes the
first thing the listener hears. So, your
ideas walk into the room already
limping. The replacement, it's simple.
Get rid of the apology. Remove the I
think. And if the idea is worth saying,
say it clean. Direct statements, no
softeners. Have a look at the
difference. Um I I I might be wrong
about this, but I think maybe we should
kind of try to post more content on
social media because, you know, it it it
will help the world uh become better
communicators. I I don't know. What what
do you think? My suggestion is we need
to post more content across our social
media because it will help the world
become better communicators. I'd love to
hear your thoughts. Vin on the left
sounds weak, unsure, whereas Vin on the
right sounded more assertive and firm.
Which one do you think is more
influential? Pretty obvious, right? On
to number seven. Rushing when you get
nervous. This happens to all of us. We
speak in front of people, we get
nervous, and because of this we
unconsciously talk faster because we
just want to get it over and done with.
And in this moment, you think speeding
up will make everything better, but in
actual reality, it does the opposite. It
makes you sound worse. Let me play you
something that will just drive this
point home.
Oh, my goodness, that sounds so bad. It
sounds like a car crash. What you just
heard was one of the most beautiful
piano pieces ever written by Chopin,
played at two times speed, three times
speed. Every note was correct, but your
brain registered it as a bloody car
crash. Now, here's what the piece sounds
like when it's given room to breathe.
>> [music]
>> Ah,
>> [sighs]
>> so much nicer. It's the same notes, but
a completely different experience. And
the difference is exactly what rushing
does to your communication when you're
nervous. Everything you actually wanted
the listener to feel gets lost in the
speed. You might be saying all the right
things, but they are going to receive it
in the wrong way. The fix? It's
counterintuitive. When you get nervous,
your body's going to naturally want to
speed up. So, in that moment when you
notice it happen, you have to go against
it by slowing down. And when you do
this, it gives your brain more time to
think clearly. Take some more deep
breaths.
And give your words more space.
Add more pauses.
And suddenly, it signals to your nervous
system that you're safe.
Which calms you down. The moment I just
did it,
don't you immediately feel more calm,
too?
So, the benefit of doing this is that it
calms you and it calms everybody else in
your environment. And I really want you
to pay attention to how you feel when
someone else is speaking fast versus
when they slow down and get nervous. Let
me show you a real example with one of
my students. Check this out.
>> What I should be trying to do is try to
make the world a better place. I don't
have to be a law intern at at PwC or
Ashurst or what whichever, you know.
>> When we're nervous, the first thing we
do is we increase our rate of speech.
And we speak quickly because we just
want this to be over and done with. So
then we keep talking and we just keep
pacing through and then I'm going to
move on to the next thing that I did.
>> So, my parents, they grew up in China
and it became a real way of thinking
that was fully focused on two academic
performance and exterior perceptions of
success.
>> Pause. Big round of applause for that.
Good. Now,
when you went slower,
did you feel a bit more relaxed?
>> 100%.
>> Ah, okay. So, a slow rate of speech not
only makes other people relaxed, it
relaxes you.
>> Pretty crazy difference, right?
>> Now, if we want to zoom out and ask,
"Why does your body speed up in the
first place?" The answer leads straight
into the next one, which is number six.
And number six is, you make it all about
you instead of making it all about the
audience. This one is a psychological
habit that all humans have, so don't
feel bad if you do this. Say for
example, you're called to give a pitch
as an entrepreneur, you are called upon
by your team to share one of your ideas,
or you are asked to do a speech at a
wedding, a best man, a maid of honor, or
maybe you get invited to speak at a
company conference, or even the TEDx
stage. What happens immediately at that
point? You start to immediately think,
"Oh my god, what if the pitch goes bad?
Oh my god, what if I forget what I'm
going to say? What if I make a fool of
myself and embarrass the bride and the
groom? What if they don't like my talk?
What if my speech doesn't get any views?
What if they leave mean comments about
me?" It's me, me, me all the time. You
are stuck in a psychological loop
thinking about yourself non-stop. The
more self-obsessed you are, the more
self-conscious you become, and the more
you put the focus on you, the worse
speech you're going to give because
you're no longer present. You are now
stuck in your own head, which means
what? Which means you're going to
deliver poorly because there's no
cognitive capacity left for delivery. I
remember back in 2019, I was in Florida
and I was coaching a CEO to deliver a
speech to 2 and 1/2 thousand people in
his organization. And right before his
presentation, I'm backstage with him and
he's feeling really nervous. He's saying
to me, "Oh, you know, I don't think I'm
ready for this. I feel like my my suit
doesn't even look good on me today. I I
don't think I can do it. What if I say
the wrong thing? What if I forget my
lines? I don't think I'm creating the
right impression with what I'm wearing
then. Ah!" And and he was freaking out.
I had to stop him right there and then.
And I said to him, "Mate, it's not about
you. It's about the 2 and 1/2 thousand
people you are about to serve. Get out
of your damn head, otherwise I'm going
to slap you. It's not about you. You're
here to serve the audience."
And I was pretty sure he was going to
fire me after that, but he liked that I
was being a little bit spicy with him.
And you know what? That snapped him out
of it. And he went out there and he
crushed it. So, the next time you notice
this pattern starting to happen, this
loop, reverse it and become more
audience conscious. Think to yourself,
"If this message gets through just to
one person, I'm going to change the
trajectory of their career, their life,
and their level of happiness."
And think, "Today is not about me. It's
all about those beautiful souls I'm
about to speak to."
And the best thing is, once you become
audience conscious,
there's no cognitive capacity left for
you to be self-conscious, which means
there's an automatic reduction in
nervousness, anxiety, and self-doubt. On
to number five,
unblur.
Speaking your thoughts out loud. Most
people when they're put under the
spotlight and they're asked a question
that they don't know the answer to, they
default to speaking their thinking
process. And a lot of the times it's
messy and it's all over the place. It's
raw, it's confusing. Because the
listener doesn't know if you're trying
to make a point or you're still building
one in your head. Now, I just want to
flag something really quickly here. If
you actually want people to see your
thinking and hear your thinking process
in real time, that's okay.
You just need to make sure you frame it
first by saying something like, "Let me
just think out loud for a second." And
just by saying that, it gives you
permission to ramble a little as you're
finding your point and you're finding
what you want to say. But, what I'm
going to suggest is, don't think out
loud. Structure your thinking first with
communication frameworks, then speak.
Watch this. Peter, my head of content,
is about to ask me a question about the
green screen, and watch me answer this
without a communication framework.
>> Hey Evan, I'm just wondering, why did
you get a cloth green screen instead of
a paper one?
>> Paper just feels a little bit risky,
Peter. I mean, sorry, not risky. I mean,
like annoying. You know, like like the
paper, the one that we used before, it
ends up looking kind of like trashed,
you know? And like it doesn't get
weirdly stuck on specific green um
different types of green colors. The
inconsistency in paper that exists
because what probably is unnecessary.
Yeah. Did you notice how annoyed Peter
seemed? Did you feel your brain trying
to keep up? That's what it's like being
on the receiving end of unstructured
thoughts. Every idea leaves your mouth
in the order your brain produced it,
which is almost never the order your
listener needs to hear it in. Most
people communicate like this their
entire lives because nobody ever taught
them how to turn their thoughts into
words with structure. It's like ordering
something online and instead of it
arriving in a box, it turns up on your
doorstep in a pile of loose parts,
things all over the place with a note
that says, "Good luck, mate. All the
parts are there, but the listener now
has to assemble it in real time with
some pages missing from the manual."
Now, I want you to watch me talk to
Peter now using a communication
framework called Para. Hey Evan, I'm
just wondering, why did you get a cloth
green screen instead of a paper one?
>> Well,
point.
I went with cloth because it just makes
more sense for us. Action.
I've done hours of research, Peter, and
I've discovered that cloth is just way
more durable.
Result.
And the result is what you see right in
front of you here, Peter. I got it also
in the gecko green because this is way
easier to key in post. And then finally,
ask.
So, Peter, do you want to take this for
a test drive later?
>> How much better was that? Whoa, all
right. I I said we'll do the test later.
Why am I floating in space? This is
ridiculous. All right, fine. I guess
we're doing this in space. At least I
got a helmet on. Let's round out my
thoughts on this. Do you see how using
frameworks makes you easier to
understand? PARA is just one of many
frameworks that help you structure your
thinking. And I've recorded a full
2-hour training on the top three
communication frameworks that will help
you turn your thoughts into words faster
in personal and professional settings.
Scan the QR code. It's floating around
in space with me. Or you can click the
link that's in the description, and you
can access that training immediately.
Okay, Peter.
You can Oh, oh, oh, look. Oh, okay,
Peter. I see what's going on. We're
starting to go down. Yeah. Whoa, Peter,
Peter. Peter, this is going too fast.
Peter, NOT TOO FAST. PETER,
NO! [screaming]
OH, WOW, THAT WAS DRAMATIC, PETER, BUT
THANK YOU. You made that extremely
engaging for the listener. Peter surely
deserves a like and subscribe for that
one, right? Otherwise, seriously, one of
these days I will fire him. Let's stay
locked in. Number four.
Yeah, I'm leaving it blurry because I've
got a little scene here, a little
example that is an example of Vin
pre-2015.
And I don't want you to watch this to
see if you can spot what number four is
and what I'm doing wrong.
>> Have you finished writing the Weekly Vee
newsletter yet? Or actually, just when
can you get it to me? Oh, man, yeah, no
worries. now. I mean, like
before we get into that, I've got to
tell you why it's called Weekly V. I
mean, do you do you know why it's called
Weekly V? Because there's actually a
backstory behind it. Because if you look
at the V and the G, the V stands for
Vin, which is spelled V I N H. Sometimes
people spell it without the H, it drives
me crazy because it's not it's not Vin
Vin it's it's Vin with a silent H. It's
so obvious. And then the G is for the
Giang, which is which is again spelled G
I A N G. And then Weekly V because you
get a weekly email from Vin. Do you do
you see what I mean? Like that that's
the backstory, which is rather critical
as to the branding behind the whole
thing. And did you just spot it? Number
four is all backstory and no point. I
wasn't listening to Dan. Dan asked me a
simple specific question and instead of
answering it directly, I rambled a
backstory about why I call my emails
Weekly V, which he's never actually
asked for. The question was gone. And
here's what I want you to notice. What's
really happening beneath the surface
here is that you're worried that the
other person you're speaking to won't
have enough context with a simple
answer. So you overload them with the
details, which does exactly that. It
overwhelms the listener with everything
you think they need instead of what they
actually wanted in the first place. And
when this happens too often, you become
that person who everyone thinks says a
lot without saying much at all. And
trust me, you don't want to be that
person. So the fix is a small physical
habit that retrains the whole pattern.
When someone speaks to you, before you
answer, repeat the core question back to
them. Ah, the ETA for the emails? Yeah,
I'm finishing them right now and I'll
have them to you by 5:00 p.m. today at
the latest. Notice that? One short
sentence and what it does is it tells
the speaker that they've been heard. It
gives your brain a beat to actually
process what was asked, which gets you
out of your head and into the present
moment. If they want the backstory or
more context, they will ask you for it.
Or you can just add a question at the
end of the response, like this.
Did you have any questions? Did you need
any more context or clarity? Is there
anything else that I can add to make
things more clear? Now, you're
presenting the opportunity for them to
ask you if they need more details, as
opposed to you front-loading,
when in a lot of cases is just not
needed nor wanted. All right, these are
the final three, the most important, the
ones that cost you the most in your
career if you're doing them. Habit
number three, interrupting people before
they've finished talking. Oh, man, I'm
so guilty of this one. I still do this
quite often, and my wife hates it. If
you're like me, and sometimes you've got
a million things running in your head at
once, and you're in a conversation with
a friend, and they're talking to you, do
you sometimes
finish their sentences? And you do this
because you're trying to be helpful, and
you're trying to show the other person,
"Look how well I know you." But they
feel like you're just trying to rush
them to the finish line, that you don't
have the patience to listen to them. And
you know what's even worse? Often, when
you try to do this, you're often wrong,
which is even more annoying for them,
because they they now have to go, "No,
no, no, no, no, that's what I'm trying
not That's not what I'm trying to say.
Let Let me show you what I mean." I just
did this the other day with one of my
team members, and and this is how it
went.
>> Hayden, I've been meaning to talk about
>> Talk about your future here.
>> here with us. Yeah, that's right.
Because lately I've been a little bit
>> concerned about team morale. Say no
more.
>> No, Vin, I'm talking about the folder on
the
>> that contains
footage surveillance footage of you,
2007, February 14th, the one that the
police office want from us, but you
won't release the files. Is that the one
you're talking about?
>> Oh. Right, right. Yeah, I I didn't think
it was that.
I didn't think it was that.
>> Look, I was talking about the folder on
my computer that says May giveaway. It's
something you wanted to talk about to
the YouTube audience.
>> Oh, yeah, yeah. Sorry, I totally forgot.
Sorry, I forgot you were here. Listen,
this entire May we're doing giveaways
into the online course, into my virtual
stage programs, and into my in-person
workshops that's happening this August.
And if you want to join the giveaway,
just click the link below, and if you
win, all the expenses will be paid for.
So, hopefully you join. Thank you,
Peter. Oh, I forgot. I almost forgot
about that.
>> That was such a good segue, man. I don't
know
>> Yeah, and it wasn't jarring, was it?
>> No, I was Can you stop trying to finish
my
>> Sentences. Finish your sentences.
>> No, can can you stop trying to eat my
>> Sandwiches. Sandwiches.
>> No!
>> Oh, man. How annoying is that? Oh, damn
it, Vin. You're an annoying bastard. I
know, I talk to myself. It's a sign of
intelligence and insanity. Now, if
you've just watched that and thought to
yourself, "Hang on, that might be me."
Stick with me for a moment, because I
want to give you a way out. The deeper
reason as to why this happens is usually
because you're uncomfortable with
silence. You've trained yourself to fill
the gap in every conversation. So, when
someone's thinking about what to say
next, you just jump in with what you
think they're going to say, and you're
not listening anymore. Stop. Learn to be
more comfortable with the silence. So,
here's the fix, and it's two behaviors
working side by side. Note these down.
Behavior number one, when you feel that
urge to jump in, don't. Wait until
they've finished talking. Let them
complete their thought on their own.
They're a grown adult. They can do it.
And even once they've finished, don't
reply yet, either. Hold space. Sit in
the silence for a full 2 seconds, and
count it out in your head. Don't say a
single word. It's going to feel so
strange at first, especially if you're
someone who butts in all the time, but
just do it anyway, because here's what's
going to surprise you. When you hold
space for someone like that, most of the
time,
they keep talking.
They'll tell you more about their day,
or what they're experiencing, or what
they're feeling. They'll go deeper than
they were planning to, because the
silence gave them permission to.
Most people never get that much room in
a conversation. So, when they get it,
they're going to use it.
Behavior number two. If they don't go
deeper on their own and you want them to
go deeper and you want to go deeper
together, hold the same 2-second pause
and this time ask five words. Tell me
more about that.
And then go quiet again. Don't say
anything. Shut up. Don't fill the space.
Let them fill it. Those are the two
behaviors. Wait 2 seconds before they
reply and if you want them to go deeper
because they didn't do it themselves,
pause for a little bit longer then ask
for the depth by asking them the five
words I said before. Do those two things
consistently and the interrupting habit
dies on its own. Habit number two. Main
character syndrome. For seven solid
years between the ages of 21 and 28, I
tried way too hard to be interesting and
to make everything about me in every
conversation. My weekend, my latest
business, my gym routine, my
relationship drama, my childhood drama,
my next big idea. Every topic became a
doorway back into my own life. And I
know you've got someone like this in
your life. We all do. It's super
annoying and if you don't know anyone,
it means it's most likely you. Because
in this day and age, main character
syndrome is the most common
communication disease on Earth. But,
here's the tragedy. When you have main
character [clears throat] syndrome, it
feels like you're the life of the party.
You're the storyteller. You're the funny
one, right? You're the person with the
big opinions and the wild weekends.
Meanwhile, your relationships are slowly
deteriorating one by one and you don't
even notice because the people who love
you the most, they're the ones who are
likely to stay silent about it and not
say anything. Because who wants to sit
across from a friend and say, "Hey man.
You You talk too much about yourself.
It's really exhausting and actually
don't like you." Nobody wants to have
that conversation because they don't
want to hurt their friends. And then,
slowly and surely, they just start
pulling away and they stop opening up
around you because, well, you create no
space for them to open up anyway. But,
what I can tell you, based on
experience, is that in a few years, they
begin to notice their friendships
feeling hollow. Their relationships
feeling more cold, and they just don't
understand why. And I want you to pause
for a second.
Just a moment. And really ask yourself
the hard question.
Could this be me?
Because outside of this video, almost
nobody has the courage to tell you. Your
partner doesn't want to hurt you. Your
closest friend is worrying it's going to
damage the friendship. Your family will
just put up with it. Which means the
only person who could diagnose main
character syndrome
is me and you right now. And you've got
to be really honest with yourself.
Whether this is you or it's someone you
know, let me tell you what I did to cure
this. One afternoon, I was reading a
book by Dale Carnegie. It was his
classic book, How to Win Friends and
Influence People. And while I was
reading the book, I did this way. I did
this. So, I read it. I read this really
powerful line. I closed it and I went
And to me, that's how I know I just read
something epic. When I actually stop
reading, close the book, and ponder on
the very thing that I read. And this was
the sentence that stopped me. The most
interesting people in any room are the
people most interested in everyone else.
My entire life, I thought the path to
being interesting was to be the best
storyteller in the group. To make sure
my version of my weekend always sounded
more wild than anybody else on the
table. Every dinner was a competition
and I had to be the winner. That one
line from the book changed the way I
thought about this completely. Think
about the last person you walked away
from and thought, "Wow, that person's
amazing." Nine times out of 10, they
barely spoke about themselves. They
asked about your life and they listened
like they had all the time in the world.
Weeks later, they could still recall the
things you were talking about. The cure
is a ratio. For every story that you
tell about yourself, ask three questions
to the person in front of you. Three for
one. Don't be the person that just keeps
talking about themselves. I hope I've
made that very, very clear. Be the
person who asks the other people
questions. A first question, then a
second question, then a third question.
If people leave a conversation feeling
seen, feeling heard, and feeling
understood, they'll remember you as more
interesting than anyone else they've
ever met. And this now leads me to the
final bad speaking habit that you need
to get rid of before it defines you. Bad
habit number one is
sounding the same your whole damn life.
Yep, sounding the same your whole damn
life. Most people get stuck in a default
way of communication and they become
attached to this one way of speaking
because they think, "This is how I speak
normally, so in order for me to be
authentic, this is how I should speak
for the rest of my life." No. No. No.
No. Do you know what the problem with
this is? If this is how I normally talk
in every situation in my life right now,
how do you think people would define me?
What would they think of my personality?
Yeah, they'll think I'm pretty boring
and disinterested, right? Because the
truth is, your voice is your
personality.
People perceive your personality through
the way you use your voice. And if you
use your voice in just one way, that
version of you is the reputation people
create for you. I I want you to
understand what I'm about to say here.
There isn't just one version of you. You
are a multi-dimensional human being.
There are infinite versions of you. You
use your voice differently in different
contexts, [music]
in front of different people, and in
different environments. You're different
in all of those different situations.
For example, when I talk to you through
a camera lens, this is how I need to
communicate in order to effectively get
my point across to engage you on the
other side of the screen. But, when I
stop recording and I go to have lunch
with my team, I back off a little bit.
I'm a little more playful, and I talk in
a much more light-hearted way. And when
I get home to play with my kids, you
better bet your ass I get even more
high-pitched and really be playful with
my voice because they love it. When dad
does this and dad gets all silly, they
have a really good time. But, then when
I'm halfway through playing with my kids
and I get a call from Peter, all of a
sudden, who's really upset now about how
much I keep interrupting him, then I
might go into a more serious tone. And
then when he starts crying, then I might
be a little more apologetic and say,
"Sorry, Peter. I didn't know you were so
soft." Did you get the point that I'm
trying to make here?
I use my voice differently depending on
the situation that I'm in.
And so should you. And does that make us
fake if we do this?
No, it doesn't. I can tell you right
now, most people never change the way
they communicate because they're afraid
of sounding fake and phony. But, I'm
going to share with you a metaphor now
that's going to break this false belief
and get you unstuck.
Your voice is an instrument. It's like a
piano with 88 keys. Imagine that, right?
Most people spend their entire lives
only playing with five keys on their
piano, and they don't realize that the
goal is you've got to learn how to play
with all 88 keys. Learn how to play the
whole damn instrument. To me, this is
authenticity.
Inauthenticity is when you're just
playing like this. To me, this is
inauthentic. Authenticity is when you're
able to express your full self. Because
once you truly understand this, you're
no longer going to feel trapped when you
play those new keys, you don't start to
think they're fake and phony. You just
go, "Oh, right. Right, right, right,
right. I'm just really familiar with
these five keys. These other keys I'm
playing with over here, and these other
keys I'm playing with over here,
they are just unfamiliar."
And the moment you think [music] they're
unfamiliar as opposed to fake and phony,
now you've freed yourself to explore
your whole darn instrument, the one
you've been [music] carrying your entire
life, which allows you then to not be so
attached to who you are in the present,
[music] so you can give the future
version of you a chance. And when you
can learn how to use your voice in the
most effective way, in the right
situations, you become truly [music]
influential. So, tell me, which habits
do you need to change and work on? Leave
me a comment below, and click this video
[music] if you want to dive deeper down
the rabbit hole of mastering your
communication skills. See you in the
next video.